it's Friday and apparently everyone here
in the office is super busy or something
so they brought in me I'm Justin the
hobo who lives outside the GameSpot
offices I'm here to bring you the week's
news hobo news like peanut butter and
chocolate something sound weird but
actually go really well together and
Blizzard is working to achieve that
conflicting awesomeness with its new
overwatch character the support sniper
on us anna is a character who uses her
sniper rifle and other abilities to
simultaneously heal her teammates and
hurt her foes and she just so happens to
be fair his mother she isn't live in the
game just yet but you can try out for
yourself through the public test realm
on pc / biotic rifle fires long-range
darts that restore your allies health or
deal ongoing damage to enemies in
addition to the rifle anna has a sleep
dart which knocks enemy is unconscious
we also learned this week that players
can expect some changes to competitive
play and over watches near future there
will soon be a one hero limit which will
prevent teams from having multiple
players using the same here oh and when
season 2 commences sudden death will be
removed in favor of ending a game at a
time the Nintendo NX is still a long way
off but in the interim the company is
releasing a mini classic version of the
NES console but it's going to be locked
in with just 30 games the NES classic
edition will launch on November 11th and
a cost of sixty dollars it plugs
directly into your TV using an included
hdmi cable and as for the games it'll
include classics like Super Mario
Brothers The Legend of Zelda and Metroid
however as many suspected the NES
classic edition doesn't connect to the
internet or use external storage devices
so the 30 games it comes with are all
you'll be able to play it will not tie
into your virtual console library also
included in the package is one nes
controller featuring a design modeled
after the original nes game pad nintendo
will sell extra controllers for ten
dollars for multiplayer games but it's
also compatible with a classic and
classic controller pro from the wii and
wii u if i told you star wars
battlefront was finally getting some
single-player content this probably
isn't what you'd be expecting star wars
battlefront developer dice has announced
it will launch a new offline mode on
July twentieth it's called skirmish and
according to lead designer Dennis
Brandel it offers players the option to
play
offline against bots in a solo mission
or with a friend using co-op split
screen on console there will be two
difficulty options for the offline mode
which is available for welker assault
and fighter squadron we also learned
that the Death Star expansion is coming
this sep tember the DLC will introduce
new grounded space maps weapons star
cards and two heroes one of these
characters is described as larger than
life and someone dice knows players have
been waiting for clearly they're
referring to fan favorite jar jar binks
music on jatta thanks mrs. your humble
servant do you like mobile games but
hate having to play them on the go well
fallout shelter is out now on PC I bet
you thought I was going to talk about
Pokemon go after millions of downloads
on iOS and Android Bethesda's popular
mobile game fallout shelter spread to PC
just this week if you haven't tried it
yet it's a free game that also offers
microtransactions and it's been a
massive hit with some 50 million
downloads to date fallout shelters
Bethesda's first mobile game though
they've confirmed that more on the way
just how big is no man's sky on 6
gigabytes of data you'll be able to
explore 18 quintillion planets but the
chances that any aliens on those planets
will be more attracted to me than Chris
Hemsworth still zero that 18 quintillion
and six gig data was provided by Sean
Murray founder of no man's sky developer
hello games and he explained that much
of that six gigs is actually taken up by
audio this is likely achieved thanks to
the fact that much of the content and no
man's sky is procedurally generated
which means there's less space taken up
on disk no man's sky has passed
certification in Europe the United
States and Asia and it's scheduled to
launch on August ninth in North America
followed by August 10th in europe in
august twelfth in the UK additionally
the studio is already busy on update 1
for the space exploration game but
details on what it'll include have not
yet been discussed but it'll probably be
space and that's it I promise next week
we'll be back to our actually talented
hosts and I'll be taken back to the
windowless basement office where I
usually work have a good weekend